well right now first responders from  mexico and israel are joining the effort  to search for survivors  in that partial building collapse in  florida this morning crews were covering  yet another body bringing the death toll  officially now to 10 but more than 150  people remain  unaccounted for there right now  questions remain about structural  problems with this building  back in 2018 engineers actually found  cracking and other issues in the  concrete columns  beams and walls the association  knew or should have known that there  were structural integrity problems  it should have been addressed at the  time that they became aware  rescuers say recovery is especially  difficult because of just how that  building fell  what they've done is actually dig a  trench under all that rubble  so far it is 125 feet long  and 40 feet deep